hello everyone we're going to intro the
show at the start of the show because we
have things about the show to explain
i know we're really falling apart here
um hi welcome to play watch listen to
the show
yeah i mean anything but play watch
listen i'm on a pierce that's awesome
entry that's mike bithell
uh we skipped last week because lives
made oh you can see my knee look at that
nice scar i have
see that oh it's really weird
uh i have this big white scar like you
normally would and then this
just big red dot that is freckle it i
mean it's really strange
it looks like rubber and it feels i
don't know it's like
like permanently it's from the from the
next three months now
so just that i don't think that's going
anywhere i had one like that for ages
and then
very slowly it went to white it's a
really weird yeah it's a really weird
texture and it's also strange because
the part where i have the lump on my
knee
is like here so this part hurts scars
all the way back here
so i feel like what happened is this hit
the road first this scraped it
so you know just uh that's an update on
my knee anyway
we didn't have an episode last week uh
because
people's lives happen and troy is not
here this week
because he hates us i believe that's the
verdict he says some pretty
pretty hurtful things yeah he's uh i
guess not doing it last week was a
the straw that broke the camel's back
for him it just yeah it did
it felt like he'd been building up some
stuff yeah no it's yeah
because we didn't give him an hour of uh
of praise as the reviews would say
he was upset and it has boycotted this
week's episode of the show
let's only talk about let's talk about
the last of us let's make our top five
list of troy's
best performances and have that be the
episode i know
five
[Laughter]
i would i feel immediately terrible i
would make that joke with him in the
room i feel terrible for doing it with
that i love yeah but
i don't feel like i have to like dm him
a confession but he's wonderful
like he's he's so good at what he does
but i feel like no one's going to be
like
does mike bishop oh that's interesting
so
your argument would be that troy has
achieved a level of
of quality in his work but it is
unbelievable to imagine
a criticism being true therefore correct
anyone saying he doesn't have
five good performances is joking clearly
wrong
yes objectively false
objectivity we have achieved objectivity
finally it's in troy baker and it's
not been long like we're barely started
and that's three minutes
yeah i know i know the one thing that
he would be so distraught to hear me say
but i don't even need five
it's just kai lang from mass effect 3
and i don't care about any other
performance he's ever given that's
totally fair
yeah i was gonna say list is done
i forgot kai lag that's that's there was
an episode we had not that long ago
where i was like
opinionated about that character it was
like i gotta go play
the crew and uh so i disappeared to go
play the crew and then it was just troy
again like i had left the podcast being
like gotta go play this game for fun
house and then it's just troy and i was
like what [ __ ]
it's just it's not an exaggeration he
really is in everything
it's too many it's silly that's that's
my main complaint about troy
um but the truth is actually not any of
the things that we said
he's just working so we thought we'd
come clean before the conspiracy
conspiracy theories grow hot i feel like
you should cut that so that we just
leave it as this mysterious like we
think they're kidding
he probably wasn't uh he probably wasn't
uh
mad at them but he is definitely not
there
yeah i don't know detroit i've got a
better idea okay
for the final edit can you go like look
for
like b-roll of him like on a red carpet
or something and just have it running as
the fourth box
the whole time muted but just so that
he's just sort of there if i can't get
into nobody i'll add a third zoom person
and it's just a pic i could probably
make that happen i'm gonna add an old
favorite
or just loop or just loop like there
must be footage of him kind of nodding
to someone's point
uh from an old episode of this that we
can just eternally
mike yeah yeah just have a loop of him
just silently agreeing along and going
this is really outdate this image he has
definitely changed himself since then i
need to wait for him he's changed it so
much since then i love that we really
are just actually still talking about
troy this whole time
exactly as he would have wanted exactly
but i did come prepared with a topic
today
is it technotaro that's what i want to
talk about it is
amazing uh no i did consider that maybe
we could talk about because this is what
the games industry is blowing up about
this week is like
what's defined as a developer but we
spoke about that like two weeks ago and
we've got it covered
it everybody yeah we're done hit
everybody a programmer is a person
theory i don't think there's such a
thing as a developer no one has ever
provably developed a video game that's
interesting you're onto something i like
it
that's my position join this call as
troy right now and see if i can make it
work
it's too complicated just for a small
bit um but no so the question that i
wanted the small bits are the
complicated ones though
nobody appreciates it all um why did
sorry go ahead no go ahead i was i was
well with only three three weeks
i love it we um we talked about
um we this whole
rqa developers blah blah blah i i fully
am on board with not spinning our wheels
too much on
on that because it's sort of silly but i
think but one time we did
glance at the topic of qa um that we nev
and there was there was a thing that i
kind of have had in the back of my mind
for probably months i don't remember
when
this came up but it was ages ago um on
the inherent
subjectivity of qa and how like the
judgment calls needed
and what they do which i think actually
really bolsters incidentally it bolsters
the argument
that they are very much part of the team
because the notion of how you
decide what are bugs and then also what
you reject as like well
we can live with that or there's not
time for that and like there's there's
so much to that process that even just
in my
capacity i've borne witness to that i
thought
there's there's actually lots to unpack
on the whole qa front if you wanted to
go there
that was my sure we can
i'm cool we're talking about qa i i know
a lot of people who actually started out
in games in qa
um i i don't know directors you know
like a lot of people start in qa i think
we've spoken about a lot of really
terrible qa working conditions i know um
ea at one point had a leaderboard for
who had worked the most hours
um like you know literally like a strive
to work for the first hours leaderboard
yeah for their qa department which is
awful um and the thing that i mentioned
this in a video recently that i find the
most fascinating about qa is people
sometimes will be like you know did qa
not do their jobs did they not test this
game
there are two parts of that obviously
it's about prioritizing which bugs you
want to fix surely qa found
most of them but also a thing that is
just very cool to think about is
it would be impossible for any studio to
hire
an amount of qa people that could equal
even the first
day's release of playtime so like even
if you're qa testing for money
even if it's even if it's modestly
successful
yeah even if it's like underperforming
you could you could qa test for
two years and still day one have more
hours played in a game
more people play testing than you could
ever possibly do throughout the entire
this is why i ensure that only 200
people in the whole world want to play
one of my games it is uh you heard
well i guess mike do you want to talk
about the the qa process for your games
or in general
like when do you stop sure um
so it does it it varies like and
different studios
qa is definitely something that does
very so much like i really speak to mine
um we i'm a big believer that like
the best way to start qa is just to kind
of not make bugs which is very easy
thing to say
but you can do some things that help
with that so we
we we do a lot of kind of processes
we're making the games to make sure that
the game's always stable a lot of games
teams will make a game
in a way that's like basically hanging
by a thread and then send it to the qa
team
and we try to keep our builds relatively
solid so the qa team
uh has to work to find bugs in it that's
that's generally our approach doesn't
mean they're not it's bug-free it just
means
that we we try and maintain that because
and similar with optimization i'm a big
believer that you can't really know if a
game's fun
if it's tripping over itself when you're
trying to play if the frame rate's
rubbish
i can't enjoy a game which is running at
10 fps so therefore
we have to make sure we maintain kind of
those kind of standards do you think
that's easier with a smaller team
hell yeah and and with a span definitely
easier with a smaller team easier with
um visually less ambitious games right
like if i was making a triple
a open world game you know those games
often the performance of those games
really only comes in right at the end
and fair enough and i'm i'm fortunate in
the kinds of games we make
yeah of course you know we can we can
get there so i'm definitely not like
lording it over
a team who's making a bigger game um our
qa process
tends to be dependent on the scale of
the game
uh we have a really great qa person
we've worked with on a couple of games
called julia who's done
um a couple of different things for us
and she is just a one person
qa nightmare you put her on code and she
will
break it elegantly specifically
find the issue she is and she is a
commando so
she just you just drop her into a game
and she'll find all the problems
so we she does our smaller stuff so um
solitaire conspiracy was her the
circular games are her
um she's working on some upcoming stuff
from us as well
when we go to a bigger project which you
know as you'd expect like
more complexity breeds more bugs we'll
work with external kind of testing teams
which is you know
usually four or five kind of people
would probably be working on a
mid-level indie game uh for us and then
the other thing of course which i think
a lot of the audience don't understand
necessarily is that you have different
um species of q18 basically you have qa
you have functional qa you have platform
qa so there are people who are meant to
make sure that like there aren't any
kind of specific issues
their quality control on behalf of the
hardware manufacturers so
xbox wants to make sure that the game
doesn't have an xbox specific problem
they they're gonna uh run you through
all that stuff that stuff's interesting
because some of it can be weighed some
big harmony way something's nba
something's not so you can have
there's some weird problems there um but
that's that's what that is and then
things like lock qa so where you
do your localization localization can
break again in a million ways so you
have a specific qa team
who are people from each of the
individual countries native speakers in
each of the languages who are testing
your game so it's
it's often a very spread out process
where like you might have
even on an indie game you might have
kind of 10 to 15 people who are
professionally trying to break the game
basically before it comes out
um on a triple a game obviously those
numbers through the roof
this is a a thing that i had never
really even thought about before but you
mentioned
uh working with someone who is like good
at
qa for whatever reason in my head of
course that's true but i've always been
like oh qa is a thing that
you know you walk in and they teach you
to do and then everyone does it the same
but
it's true that people could be really
good at qa that could be like a thing
someone could be an expert in doing
professionally i'd never even consider
that before
yeah on lots of levels so first of all
like qa requires
that's why i always get frustrated
because i think a lot of the i think
this is true even in industry i think a
lot of people fall into this traffic
if you're not directly interacting with
qa a lot um people see it as a starter
job because as you said for a lot of
people is a starter job you go there
you want to be a designer in the games
industry you do a qa job you get into
the design track and you're off but
there are a country a qa
yeah there are there are career qa
professionals and there you have like
with any profession you have
um there's an enormous amount of like
institutional knowledge like there
and even game designers have this
knowledge to a tiny extent but like a qa
professional will know
the kinds of things one does in a game
to try and break it even players who
played a lot of games will have a sense
of like
usually if i do this kind of thing i'll
break a game qa
obviously an expert can take that and
they will you can sit down a qa person
with a released game
and in two minutes they'll have figured
out a way to fall through the floor
because they
they know all the tricks of the trade
that's that's part of it that's kind of
institutional awareness
but it's also about how you process um
information so how you try and work your
way uh through a project how you
logically kind of make sure you've kind
of
tried every bit of the floor and those
kind of like methodical thinking
processes
and then crucially the biggest part of
qa is communication which is taking
i found this problem because in
professional qa you don't just say
i found a bug here's a screenshot
there's like a process you have to
explain exactly how you got there
what the it's called a repo so what did
you do what's the reproducible steps
that get you to that bug
and well i think all of us you know as
people in the games industry have
have done qa and put together an email
for someone like that but when you
compare the kind of
crappy email anyone on this call would
send myself included
to what like a professional will like
it's like it's it's a
it's a it's a menu it's a it's a
beautiful kind of work of art
um that will find this very specific
thing in a reproducible manner
um because with bugs you have rare bugs
which are a nightmare where it's like
one in a hundred times this happens the
real talent of a qa person is going
that's not chance because there's no
such thing as chance on a computer what
is the exact steps you have to repeat in
order to get that 100
of the time and then once you've got 100
of the time a it's easy for the
coder or designer who's going to fix the
bug to be able to find it in the first
place
and b we're going to know when we fixed
it because if we can reproduce 100 of
the time when we fix it we know it's
it's our faith we're not just getting
lucky that we've not seen it again
so there's this enormous amount of skill
i think like a lot of things because
bugs are something that players
encounter directly themselves
they don't necessarily think about like
the steps you need to take to
professionalize that process and give
information
and yeah anyone watching this who's ever
found a bug in a game they want to tell
a developer about
find the reproduction steps it will
multiply the chances of that bug getting
fixed by like 100.
you can find me the exact thing that
will break it every single time
i will be able to solve that problem for
you yeah i've spoken to people who work
in qa
about players um finding a bug and
reporting it
but often having no repro because they
don't know how to do that
uh so a lot of those bug reports are
effectively
um useless is not the right way that
would be selling it short but like
essentially just create a lot of work so
when you report the bug yeah
someone has to look at it and be like
okay i have to figure out how to
recreate this and that can take
hours and hours and hours and it seems
like something that like should be very
simple be like this person found this
bug at this place go in the code then
update it and hit enter and then
we fixed the bug yeah
a race bug from code but no even
figuring out
how that bug got there for that one
person it's really complicated i
remember with uh
assassin's creed unity uh some graphics
cards having that
that visual issue where you would just
see their eyeballs
um everyone's faces were morphed off but
the percentage of players who had that
was
so small in the grand scheme of things
because it was only related to one piece
of hardware that apparently recreating
that bug actually took them a really
long time to figure out
because people weren't reporting their
hardware when reporting the bug
so it's like we have no idea what's
causing this it could be a million
things how do we figure that out it's
it's uh it's a lot of puzzle solving
that goes into
qa top to bottom i think i think those
open world
the open world games also um
basically multiple orders of magnitude
more difficult to reproduce these
these bugs because there's so many
variables that
are hap like because i see this even on
the even in the narrow scope of the
music
uh you know part of part of the way i
tend to do my job
is once the score is fully delivered but
even concurrently while we're working
i'll go in and i'll play the game and
i'll try to break the music system
because i'm the one who
can clock a bug more annually than
anyone else
exactly like there are plenty of times
where people will message me and go hey
i heard this thing and then i heard this
thing and i i wasn't sure if it was
intentional or not so i don't even know
if it's a bug because like
this cue you know this big french horn
suddenly interrupting this thing
was it was kind of cool but it also was
kind of strange like so i don't i don't
really know
it was were you doing that on purpose
and what and of course it's always
disheartening when you're like
yeah no that was that was on purpose but
uh
but composition i spent all night
certainly
certainly had that happen but but yeah
sometimes i'll get i'll get bugs
assigned to me
um you know it kind of just to see if i
can pitch in
i'll get a little notification in my
email saying hey can you check out this
this bug that we found in the music
implementation and i'll
never be able to reproduce it espec you
know on an open world game like
assassin's creed or the pathless or
something it's damn near impossible
without just committing to like a five
hour play test in order to go to that
one moment
in the hopes of reproducing all the
exact steps because as soon as these
systems start talking to each other
it could even be something that happens
an hour before that one moment that's
the beginning of the trigger of the bug
eventually happening
yeah it's how would there be separate
people who do work to
qa tests music i had not thought about
that but i guess that's that is also an
important thing
is i think there is audio qa yeah
because
you will you will see um qa reports that
say things like
you know like obviously things like
dialogue
like it triggered the wrong dialogue
when i walked into this room or blah
blah like theoretically a game play
sort of like you know whatever the term
would be but a a generic
qa person that's just looking for
anything wrong with the game would be
able to spot something like that but i
have heard of audio specific
people or things that are like you know
lip sync
uh uh malfunctions you know all those
kinds of
uh of things but i do get pushback funny
enough you know there's a movie
equivalent to this process as well
that's part of the
the movie distribution you know of a
movie equivalent
i know right because i've gotten
pushback i've gotten flagged before on
movies that i scored there was one movie
in particular a long time ago
where there's a scene where it's this
amazing
film is a jordanian film where there's
this
uh old man in the neighborhood who has
discovered that
uh one of the young boys in the
neighborhood is being
really kind of badly abused by his
father so he decides to
you know intervene and and so the boy
has been ushered off away from home for
the night and he's going to confront the
father so there's just this scene where
he's in the guy's house just pouring
himself a glass of water just waiting
for the guy to come in the front door
knowing like
this guy is going to flip the [ __ ] out
when he realizes i've essentially taken
his son away and said
you need help you you are you are a
destructive
monster and so there's this shot of him
where just we're just slowly pushing in
on him
and then we reverse and we're slowly
pushing in on the doorknob and the
director decided
let's go all the way to literal digital
zero there's not even room tone
it's just complete and total silence and
every time i saw
i sat in screenings of this movie many
many times it played in
festivals and stuff all over the world
and there was this year-long period
where we kept watching it over and over
and over with new audiences and it was
always
that moment was so intense because no
one dared breathe
in the whole theater because it was such
this culminating but of course when the
film was getting released theatrically
and on dvd and all that
there was like the movie equivalent of
qa i think it's called qc
quality control it's the same idea where
there's people that are i don't think
you'd be able to release
that on a console or on a couple of the
consoles is as a game
absolutely silence would actually be a
flag on on some of the console
really exactly tlc process yeah i think
so yeah they pinged it as
you know uh we think that you have a
book you know your room tone disappeared
and whatever and we had to kind of
do the waiver process of saying no
that's that's on purpose and they
it's almost like appealing a judge where
you have to say
you know we promise that's artistic
license and not uh a technical fault
because it's their job we promise to fix
it in the day one patch can you
there it is yeah that looks like they do
it now i mean
they do with cats right they did some
stuff like that yeah game of thrones
and and and uh justice league did a day
3000
pass
yeah so yeah it was a big actually i
guess it wasn't anywhere near 3000
days but that'd be like 10 years yeah
i'm upset that you didn't have the days
accurate
yeah what did you guys think have you
guys seen kung kong uh
be godzilla watched hours late to all of
these things
i i watched that and snyder cut i have
opinions
that seems like a heavy turns out that's
not a good way to watch them no i
thought it's louder i had no yeah i had
exactly i
was like you know i had no that's just
the only way
you could be 0.01 predisposition towards
like epilepsy but if you watch both at
the same time it's guaranteed because
it's just
visual noise to the extreme one of
them's got a lot of slow mo
i feel like you could like maybe take
some breaks in those periods of time
really true i think you could also watch
twice during the run time of
snyder cut uh well we can talk about
those things if you like
but my my question which is kind of
related to the qa conversation um
something that i think we've slightly
spoken about before
uh especially considering the caliber of
the the games that
the two of you have worked on was for
anyone
meaning what mediocre yeah
the word is nonsense but but indie or
indie adjacent
um how important do you think it is
for indie devs or even you know people
who work
in qa to have a presence on twitter
because it was just like it occurred to
me that last week with all this judgment
which for the record i realized we never
actually established
um the the conversation about what is a
game dev and what isn't came
uh because of a forbes writer who i
guess used to work in
game dev tweeted something along the
lines of this is
absolutely not what he said but the
start of it was essentially uh if you're
on a programmer
you aren't a developer you shouldn't
call yourself a developer
he's talking about his japanese friend i
don't know but then i think the thing
that mostly got the negative response
was that he said people would only say
that out of ego
um so that you know worked up a lot of
twitter and a lot of people had
opinions on if they're devs or not and i
i've said this before i don't i do not
care if someone would say that i am or
am not a game developer but i do have it
in my social media bios for a very
specific reason it says gamedev
writer is because upon announcing it
everyone assumed that i was marketing or
pr
um not that those things aren't
inherently game dev but to most people
that
is more specific if i just have writer
or video game writer
uh i don't know if it's because of my
background or because i'm a woman they
tend to just assume
comms so i i have that very specifically
to be like i'm doing
the this part of uh the production of a
video game not that people who
do those facets of it are not not in
fairness i feel like that's
not a difficult uh mistake to make to
assume that you would
that you would be in the comms side of
it considering that that would be
a lot of the main points of contact that
you would have been interfacing with i
would think right as a
as a yeah a lot of people know from me
for a journalist to cross over in that
way i guess
but yeah yeah whereas what you did is
far less st like
you're you're you made you made a huge
shift
it's actually it seems to me i mean i
know
more people who've gone directly from
being games journalists to being video
game writers than
games journalists to comes but i know of
people but like of personal friends more
of them have gone directly to writing
video games
it's definitely a thing that happens
it's definitely a thing yes that's me uh
i i won't be friends with the comms
people
that's ridiculous one of my best friends
is combs that suck a punch
um but yeah i mean are you pulling me
some of my best friends work in comps
i am exactly some of my best friends
work in comps it's true one of my
friends just started using stuff and
comes this week okay
so i know lots of people in comms it's
not you know really it's really cool of
you to like be
friends with comms people it's like
really it says a lot about you like
we hang out um i think i really
understand what they do you need the old
yeah
like they're yeah like you know it's
different like it's obviously not as
of course like did you ever uh watch
colbert report back in the day when he
would he would
he had this running gag about like when
he played
he was playing a kind of bill
o'reilly-esque character for that show
and so it was constant recurring motif
of like his
the one black friend and he had this one
stock photo he would always use
of him going next to this next to this
very uncomfortable looking guy that's
like clearly never met him before
very you need a you need you need a you
need a comms person
photo of you that you can recreate i
have plenty i have okay because i have
so then it ruins it you need
one point being regardless yeah i don't
i think it's it's probably because a
because of how people
know me but i'm not gonna tell you there
wasn't some sexism in that because there
was so much of people being like what on
earth would you know about writing
fiction she should go work on
social media teams like there was like
it was very specific language directed
at
this woman does not know what she is
doing um that i feel like my
my male colleagues do not get sometimes
people tell me i should just go straight
to
uh porn so you know some of that is
rooted in sexism a little bit i think
um but regarding porn in fairness
is there an indirect route to porn
through video games
straight to it in fairness the the the
level the
bar for quality of narrative writing in
porn is
you could stand to raise that bar and
i'd probably enjoy it
i feel like you would find probably
inject some creativity
yeah i know there are a lot of really
specific rules about porn writing uh
especially in
uh the us where you know if there's
a welcome oh it's on me welcome to the
show everyone
if uh if porn is advertised as being
like you know the step sibling or
sibling thing
it must be established at a certain
frequency throughout the narrative that
they are not actually related
so you have to say a certain amount of
times in uh like a full published video
i don't know how that applies for
websites that just take chunks of videos
or whatever
um but it has to be said with enough
frequency that they are not blood
related you have to
write that into the script so people are
like why are they talking
so they can get away with incest but
they have to repeatedly say that's not
related
they do they clums so they're just you
know
during the scenes just clumsily throwing
we're not related
i think it's really it just has to be
established this is fine everyone
yeah okay my favorite uh there was a
there was
years ago i'm really worried about where
this is going
my favorite you should be terrified like
your favorite walk
years ago on uh on cnbc there was like
this two-hour special that they re-aired
like a thousand times of
the economics of the porn industry and
how it was like this because this was
probably
10 or 12 years ago so it was kind of
right when the internet was
was sort of putting the nail in the
coffin on the
on the sort of traditional very
profitable
porn industry and shifting to the wildly
i think
unprofitable internet version um and so
they were talking about how
there was profitable uh yeah but i think
it's nothing compared to like the heyday
of
the girls gone wild vhs and [ __ ] like
that
mike biffle's podcast recommendation
there's a john ronson
i'm gonna have to look up what it is
there's a john ronson podcast where he
talks about the economics of like
basically yeah so yes internet
pornography is
is it makes a lot of money but only for
the tech companies the host
rather than for the performance oh yeah
performers get ripped off it's like
but they didn't used to i think this was
ever thus right like
like workers i don't know if i've
mentioned socialism on the show before
um but yeah what are your thoughts well
in any case the uh the thing that was
pro workers that's my that's my stance
the thing that was so fascinating was
that they
realized uh there was this experiment
that they engaged i never actually
looked to see if this ended up working
but the thing that they spotlighted
heavily in this
um documentary was that um
they filmed a full feature length
pirates of the caribbean
parody porn film but they specifically
wrote it such that
they could cut all the sex scenes and
sell it as a kids movie in like japan
um because it was amazing because it was
basically just a
cheap pirate's knockoff with bad actors
if you just got rid of all the
that would have been quite hard actually
i think that made it at the time the
highest budget
in the movie the butterfly effect is the
name of the podcast
by the way if anyone wants to listen to
the world it's really interesting like
if you're an economics
like nerd it's called the world it's
fascinating the butterfly effect
butterfly effect
it's yeah it's john ronson who's an
investigative journalist from
ashton kutcher and amy smart sega
with ashton kutcher and amy smart as
guest hosts
that's right yeah yeah yeah he's he's
amazing at the uh the mixes um but yeah
it's really good it's um yeah because
that whole industry
kind of fell apart but in like a very
interesting way um
it's what we talked about pretty wild
yeah we can circle back to the question
but i didn't wanna
yes i did want to bring up uh mia
khalifa
who i would say is a very famous
ex-pornstar
um i know her from an episode of kind of
funny i think i think that's where i
know
she's she's a friend of mine she's cool
uh but she went public
about having only made twelve thousand
did my webcam do the thing where it
dropped me down for no reason
have i looked like you're sorry i was
gonna respect it i don't understand why
it does it but anyway
she only made twelve thousand dollars
during i it was it was a pretty
short amount of time that she was in uh
she actually even worked in the industry
um and considering them knowingly like
she was in a bunch of stuff like those
those guys work like yeah but it's also
you do a lot of films right presumably
yeah um the stuff that she was in has
millions of views
uh but it doesn't matter um and i know
that like i guess
her report was refuted by bang bros who
she may have been working for who said
that she made 178
000 but i mean she maintained she only
made 12 000 which is absolutely absurd
and she's also spoken about like really
exploitative contracts and
all of that kind of stuff where like a
lot of uh adult film stars feel like
they're forced to sign
kind of on the spot um a lot of that's
awful and fascinating but also like i
feel like um
just to even tie that to video games uh
i have always been interested in
preemptively impressed with the
connection you're about to make
we've always been interested to see how
successful vr porn
can be because in a lot of cases the
minute porn is successful on a platform
it can make the platform successful they
say that a big part of vhs taking off
was porn being
successfully or accessible on vhs so
i've tried vr porn before i did it at a
ces and it was awful and uncomfortable
and i
really hated it like extremely
uncomfortable experience because there's
no consent
so it's just pov watching something that
looks like it's happening to you
uh and before they they put it on me
they were like just to let you know
most women really hate this so i tried
it she
took it off laughing within like 10
seconds
a brilliant foundation for anybody yeah
they were like just to be
yourself right now for women
it feels a bit rapey and we we recognize
well yeah because there is no need to
fix that
no so it's just a dude walking into a
room and then just stuff happening and
you can't move and i'm like what if i
don't like this thing
it looks like it's happening to me where
it's like if you're watching a video you
scrub through it
very very uncomfortable there's one
thing not like i want
in that situation it's to be completely
blindfolded to my surroundings
like that's the that's the like it
doesn't seem like an activity you would
want to do without peripheral vision
in terms of viewing pornography like it
feels like you would want
i think a lot of people would disagree
with you just cut to
mike on a bus in the vr thing like holes
in the sides of it so we can see
but you want to know right you want to
know like if people if something is the
rule
that is true yeah i mean a lot of
teenagers
it's a lot of trouble yeah it's very
catered to
you know like you know non-roommate
bachelors i guess uh i guess that's the
primary market oh people
at ces but yeah it was it was atrocious
and i don't think i'd ever do it again
unless they had like
not that i think i'd ever do again
anyway but uh input like choose your own
adventure input or like a stop button
because yeah he straight up said women
all
all hate this whereas i love the guy i
love the ideas
gamifying the consent you know where
it's like a guy walks up to you and
you're like
you know and he just turns and leaves
and that was your porn and you're like
i could get off to that just saying no i
mean that would be you're having sleep
specifically for that
i think that's the dream like it's also
a really
weird set of technical challenges i've
not i've i've never
never gone to that ces booth um i guess
i was doing something else but like
it was in the cosmopolitan hotel it
seems
really weird it seems like whereas it
really was in a hotel
yeah it was in a cringing yeah and then
all the food was served by ex-porn stars
who were about 60 years old
and were willing to talk to you at any
point like they were like just ask them
about their experiences
it was like i will take them
but like it's such a weird having no
experience i don't know and i'm
interested in your
opinions on this it seems like such a
ridiculously
hard hurdle to jump in the sense that
you have to
to make it immersive like humans are
always the hardest thing to show
in an interactive context because your
brain knows what it's like to lock eye
contact with another human
i would have assumed like an intimate
situation like that
it's gonna be weird like even just like
a scale discrepancy like presumably like
with video on vr
every vr video i've ever seen i've
either felt like i was three feet tall
or ten foot tall you know i think most
you meant something like this man won't
have a problem with a scale discrepancy
uh in the context of wearing a vr
brilliant
yeah the scale was a massive problem um
but i think that they've made so i only
tried it that one time i've not
revisited it
um but you know it looked like you had a
monster on top of you even if i tried
the one that was for the male
perspective
it was all very heterosexual so it was
just like a giant
towering woman on top of you uh that one
did not make me uncomfortable in the
same way but it was like
comical because the scale was such a big
problem but i believe
that a lot of the companies working on
the tech have have improved that over
time
uh it seems like it seems like an
uncanny valley really hard to do
um i remember related to this i remember
when um
google glass and and some of the other
uh
peripherals were coming out offering
uh ar type tech you know
distinct from this people were talk i
remember reading an article or maybe it
was something on twitter i can't
remember where i picked this up so this
could be something really random but i
i remember somebody talking about it's
effectively
effectively both people wearing these
where their camera is being fed the
perspective of the other
and i was like why is that appealing
that's basically you looking at yourself
but for both of them
mirrors mirrors in hotel rooms are
pretty popular i understand
i think that's what they're doing in
demolition man i always wondered what
their weird vr sex is
we just re-watched that the other day
and hilah had never seen
the first time the other day that is a
great movie it's excellent it is good
it holds up it's so damn funny and i
love
yeah and i love i and it was actually
such a like that scene in particular to
watch in the context of a pandemic where
he's
she's like fluid exchange oh yeah
yeah so so i was like that that that
hurts that's straight that's that's too
real
yeah how disgusted they are by i was
like they actually did a lot of stuff
pretty well in this movie they predicted
a lot of stuff
so damn talk about the big one in
reference to an earthquake
and we had a really bad did did it wake
you the earthquake the other night
austin
you know it's funny i i i did nope it
did not i was i would not have known if
it weren't for social media i wouldn't
have known
it happened it was loud like i've never
you know had earthquakes here plenty
things shake a bit that one was like it
wasn't the epicenter like englewood or
somewhere because that was
it was the airport i think yeah yeah
okay yeah cause i think i think the
valley was
sequestered off from the impacts of that
one because sometimes i definitely feel
him
um i had this period of time where i i
was so
convinced that at every moment an
earthquake would happen that i'd bump my
own table
see like a glass move and think oh this
was it because i just
instantly would have the amnesia of my
own body causing it and just
look this is the moment i think that
earth earthquakes are happening quite
frequently in l.a like all the time i'll
be like something shook is it an
earthquake but it's not it's just a
thing like a truck
terrified of them anyway to walk this
backwards demolition man good still not
sure what that vr sex is
uh vr porn uh hopefully successful
because then in theory
vr as a platform is more profitable and
heads in a good direction and i just
made uh or just published a video today
which will have been a few days ago
about some of my favorite vr games that
i've been working out in
they are fantastic so good at like it's
really good for them oh my god
getting cardio in like just getting your
heart rate up and not realizing that
you're doing it
obviously your face gets sweaty and that
sucks a bit but it's such a good way to
work out as someone who hates cardio
uh because you you just forget that
you're you're actually working out in
the real world rather than playing a
video game such a fan highly recommend
even to anyone who's like
afraid to get into fitness it makes you
also a lot less self-conscious i think
because you're just not thinking about
what your body is doing or what you look
like
huge fan highly recommend i use the
oculus quest too
walk back that to qa i
think it's where we imagine
i was going to say that qa people listen
to this podcast that are like we've
finally been heard
of 20 minutes and then we're like so vr
porn the cosmopolitan at ces
at least you've got your clickbait title
for youtube yes right like at least
you've got that's true
i've got options to choose from i think
i've
told this story before here but my
favorite qa related story
was on alien isolation where they told
me that um
the they had developed their interactive
music system to
to make these big nasty musical swells
when the xenomorph was close by
and they discovered a bug or a qa
reported a bug where you know you'd hide
in the locker
and then the music would swell because
of a false positive and the xenomorph
wasn't there
and it made the game so much more
terrifying
because you weren't sure if it was there
or not that they just shipped it with
the bug
they left it in because they thought it
was it added so much to the gameplay it
was a happy accident that it didn't
actually break the functionality of the
game it was just the music misfiring
and i was like that is very scary uh oh
until the point that it's not i had
this problem where i stopped finding it
scary the first time it's probably
halfway through
that you see the xenomorph on a loop you
actually
watch it in one of the rooms walk around
in a circle and the minute that that
happened the minute i felt like it was
on a track i was and i understood what
it was doing i feel like it just was
never terrifying again i was more afraid
of the uh it's a lot like vr pornography
once the illusion is broken
exactly and you don't have consent and
it's terrifying
uh you just want to throw it away
xenomorph did not respect consent
probably not that's definitely well the
flamethrower uh it kept its distance if
you held the flamethrower to it that's a
form of
consent yeah you know yeah it was like
it was taking away
all the flamethrowers yeah you yeah you
you all keep my distance if i'll be
charred to a crisp
i still maintain that that game is too
long but it is very good
uh somehow i i i i'm normally that guy
as someone who loves
like i was stationed before yeah i think
we definitely have
i can tell the loop i'm like it's like
seeing the alien loop around the room
sometimes on this show
yeah this conversation i don't know if
we've spoken about vr porn before but it
is it is pretty fascinating tech i
feel like that one's new territory i'm
really disappointed we're basically
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and also i have friends in college true
so
full circle on all of it um but no uh
the people i know who work in qa who
have worked
in qa ah it's a very thankless job like
i said earlier in a lot of cases
contract there are a lot of people
who uh do qa in la that basically jump
between the studios as needed and it
sounds like some of those people are
happy doing that and enjoy doing that
but in a lot of cases it's
it's very um especially publicly yeah
thankless work it's it's a lot of work
it's very very very important to the
development of a video game
you need qa um and you'll get blamed if
it's not perfect even though that is
not generally qa's fault it is generally
a scope
fault it's a right it's a never q a
qa found the bug that you're
experiencing probably
and ultimately someone in my position
went ah super rare won't be a problem
yeah that's that's how it always works
out and you have to
rank them mike you should you should
talk about the the subjective appraisal
of this is
game breaking therefore it cannot be
allowed to stay in the game versus this
is
you know does this ruin the game or not
yeah yeah it's i mean basically what
austin just said we have different
grading systems so an a-class bug is
like ah
um yeah usually you have the concept of
game breaking so
uh so uh literally it breaks the game
um crash you know as a user would call
it
uh you have progress blockers so there's
bugs that stop you from progressing any
further or often
maybe tied like a save game bug but
those there's different relations for
that
i think my favorite class of bug which
is no seriously we can't release a game
with this ridiculous thing
um which cannot wobble depending
entirely on the uh creative
director's kind of opinion my audacity
has crashed for the second time on this
call so i'm going to reopen that
oh wow it's going to be a nightmare i'm
so sorry for the editor jumping down and
apparently without troy we're just a
bunch of people
um are you do you have a backup audio
alarm for this
yeah i i have backup audio yeah yeah but
it is bad
it doesn't ever sound good i believe
this will light back up again before i
continue
i think it's isn't it zoom capturing the
um the compressed
input that you're getting through the
internet basically
through obs but yeah i mean that is
the effect so if the audio in this
section is
for the podcast there we go um
so one thing i wanted to just throw in
actually because it is a bit of advice
that still floats around the industry
that i think is important
is what's happened with qa is
traditionally many
you know decade or two ago qa would be
internal within a company
um and they would generally be um static
they wouldn't be
hired and fired at quite the rate that
you mentioned earlier like people
bouncing around
so the advice the common advice was hey
if you want to get into the games
industry go in through qa
i made a choice in terms of when i'm
talking to students i don't make that
recommendation anymore qa
arguably isn't a great path into um core
game development if you want to be on a
development team doing design code
qa still developers but if you want to
be on the internal team making the game
itself
i think we're at a stage now as an
industry where there are better parts in
and there's a lot of people who get
trapped in that loop as you say of kind
of bouncing between if you want to be a
qa person
go and join the qa department that's
great um i'm going to push back on the
idea that the qa department is not
making the game itself
i think they are that's a choice that's
a terminology thing i mean in terms of
literally if you want to be on the
development team doing design code um
art someone basically if you want to be
sat if when you're imagining
your dream job in games you're sat
on an internal dev team at a company
like naughty dog
between the level designer and the coder
then qa is generally quite separate
nowadays to get into that role i'm not
diminishing the role of qa as i said at
the start i have an enormous amount of
respect and it's a vital part of the
process
but it is not the gateway job it used to
be
because um because those teams are now
either geographically removed from the
teams or they are
you know people on bad contracts frankly
where they're constantly being fired and
rehired
so if you want to work in qa go work in
qa it's a cool job and if you're
and if you you know if you enjoy that
kind of work you're going to have a
great time doing it
but i do think the advice of getting get
your foot in the door
via qa is a little out of date and a
little bit never give up
games complex segments sorry i was gonna
say i don't think i'd ever give anyone
that advice unless they specifically
wanted to do that thing
oh i i hear that still from people
saying hey if you want to be a game
designer go and do qa
i i think it's useful i think the
experience of doing qa is in itself
useful for a designer because it gets
you into the analytical logical thinking
that is a big part of design thinking
but it used to be that you could go into
a qa department and catch the attention
of the designers
and get promoted into the design
department that's much harder to do now
because of the degrees of separation
that exist
between those disciplines um so it's not
a value judgment
definitely not value judgment it's it's
more about literal geography and how
those teams fit in
be realistic with what people's goals
are that's not necessarily yeah the
right path to take and i guess um
related to that back to my original
question
do you think that people trying to get
into the games industry where qa or or
not uh particularly in the any space
need to have a presence on twitter
all right that's definitely trying to
remember the original question
i do i don't think they do and i think
increasingly i think maybe that's a bad
idea
that's part of what i was thinking is i
feel like might have scared people away
this week and that's kind of why i
wanted to ask but i've had i've had
people in the comments before i ask us
this question and ask if we wanted to
talk about it it's like
for games journalists i would say yes
you need to be on twitter
um that is building up those contacts
and sharing articles
having people see the things that you've
read it acts as a digital portfolio that
a lot of people will actually be able to
see
rather than when it's on a blog or a
website or whatever else i think it's
very very important and yeah for
contacts of course like you need to be
in touch with
pr people you need to be making contacts
with developers
definitely very very important um in my
job role now i don't think that i
actually need twitter i don't think to
be a video game writer i don't think
that i need to be on twitter
but i do feel like it is still very
helpful regardless to get into the
industry because dear god the games
industry is so
very on twitter like so much new very
online
is on a tweet like it's very very common
so it's definitely a part of it
um but i don't know that i feel like
it's necessary across the board
uh austin how do you feel about the idea
of people in your vocation
i i get asked that by students and such
all the time
um and there are a couple of composers
that have
have cultivated uh or just
happened into one way or the other um uh
you know pretty robust online presences
um and so there's a
tendency or a temptation to look at that
and sort of attribute their success
to that and or or at least
think of it as part of the variable
of their success and i generally think
that that's probably not true i think
generally you get career opportunities
because one people like working with you
you're easy to work with you're reliable
you deliver on time you know your
your your you can keep your cool under
pressure and stress and all that and
then obviously if the quality of the
music is
at least good enough um and uh
past that everything else is basically
bonus you know there are lots of
composers
who are you know hyperactive on twitter
and have
no career to show for it and then
there's
others that are just working 24 7
and incredibly successful that don't
have never even
fought to make social media in fact some
of the older guard like alan silvestri
and
john powell and danny elfman you know
the composers that are that are kind of
a generation or two uh older than
than mine in the last you know
year to two years have kind of decided
to dip their toes in and they have the
most endearing and charming social media
presence alan silvestri in particular
because it's always like
him with a glass of wine like good good
evening or what and it's like
knowing that you know yesterday he
scored like [ __ ] the avengers or
whatever but it's just
you know he's just this incredibly
congenial wonderful man
and um so yeah i i don't think it's
i don't think it's necessary it doesn't
hurt the one advice that i always give
is
do it if you think you can be yourself
don't i don't treat it as
a marketing platform because i always
any time i follow someone and then i
realize that all they use it for
is to say hey check out this newest
release of this and this
and it's not a dialogue platform it's
not a chance to interact with them but
it's just
that's why i have my commuted yeah
exactly
totally understood and i don't know
what to do mike you know i'm just i
don't want to do it you should wish list
them that's all i'm saying you should
wish list
it's a simple message and it comes from
the heart
wishlist my games contradicting yourself
from earlier in this year you said don't
buy any of your games
i know it's like you can't be asking
neither of you got that reference i hope
the comments do
what you just made a reference that i
didn't understand i did to a brilliant
work of art it's fine it doesn't matter
the great the greatest
song ever written i think actually was
doesn't matter somewhere over the
rainbow
that's a pretty good song well no it's
more of a big deal that we didn't get
the reference yeah because we've drawn
attention to it and now it's insecure
weird now let's become weird
i really the best way to avoid now i've
drawn you in
am i going to get canceled on twitter
because i don't know the reference
you should wishlist my game that's
that's the lesson now
um so what this is actually an excellent
demonstration on which list my game is
like cardi b's newest single and we just
don't know it
that's what it is why not all is up to
date
i'm an actor this has been one big build
up to that release
the record's dropping hell of a couple i
think i don't know about twitter i
really don't i have a
kind of a definite kind of uh faustian
pact with twitter
because i i definitely i definitely
wouldn't have the career i have if i
hadn't been like
an early twitter person but at the same
time like it's such a source of stress
and frustration and anxiety for me i
don't know
if i could i'd walk away for tomorrow
but i think i kind of still need a
little bit to promote stuff
that said most people at start their
careers are not actually
responsible for promoting games so i
think you can probably keep your head
down
and probably don't also have the same
level of stress that someone like you
might have
twitter is stressful regardless because
of what you intake but it's also what
people throw at you is
disproportionately higher the longer
you're on
that's true i'm lucky in that extent
that people are generally pretty cool to
me on there but
but still yeah yeah of course um the um
yeah i don't know i don't know i think i
think as well
it's also it can be a very perilous
position for a younger dev like we
definitely
something we're very conscious of as a
company that
if we release a game and someone doesn't
like it there's a non-zero chance that
people are going to find out
the one woman uh who was related to
a feature they didn't like other of the
team and they're going to go after that
person
on social media so you're definitely
definitely like an exposure for young
devs there
and you see it time and again right like
a games being unpopular
the worst parts of the internet are
gonna find out the the three women who
were in
in that team or in that area or whatever
and they're gonna lay into them
it happened really badly with mass
effect andromeda they were very specific
about who they targeted to blame for
that game
it was pretty awful to watch and the
reality is with a triple a game
the person you're angry at does not have
a twitter
that person is nowhere near they're off
with social media
yeah bonus they're doing fine they can't
get to their laptop for the piles of
cash
so like yeah it's always it's always
it's always deciding to see so that's
definitely something that like for
younger devs there is a there is a risk
that you become
the the the center of a storm that you
really
really really didn't you know deserve
i think i've also seen people sorry um
i've also seen people
uh particularly on the journalism side
but there was definitely one instance of
of someone who was uh in development
slash programming
um sort of hurt their careers by the way
that they conducted themselves on
twitter
you know to austin's point about like
people getting hired because they're
easy to work with if you come across as
though you are not on twitter
that can hurt your higher ability and i
think the problem with younger people
using it and not knowing that
is that they shoot themselves in the
foot where career opportunities are
concerned
way too early and the way that i think
i've seen that the most common
uh way i've seen it particularly people
looking to get into journalism
um was people acting like they knew more
than everyone else
on twitter replying to every game day of
replying to every other journalist
telling them they're wrong and that they
know more with something that's like
nobody is going to work with you but i
think when you're young
and you do think you know everything uh
you also don't know well enough
that that makes you seem like a
douchebag and not well informed it
doesn't make people want to work
some of them not some of the worst stuff
i've been sent on twitter or the most
not
worst as in awful but just like rude
just like crit
insulting on a personal level or
whatever has been from someone who when
i've clicked on them their profile says
aspiring game developer yeah dudes like
i'm not a quote tweet guy like it's not
my vibe i don't do that it doesn't it
doesn't suit my
my style on on twitter but at the same
time like you
just tried to wind up someone who has a
voice in the games industry
what are you doing like why are you
picking this fight
um it's a lesson you can learn too late
sort of the point there is like some
people
don't you shouldn't be saying the things
some people will quote tweet you and you
will become the protagonist of twitter i
think
i think the other two really naive
beliefs on behalf of the person
because i've i've seen compo you know
younger composers do the exact same
thing you're talking about
and i think that the double the double
whammy of
naive beliefs that they've internalized
that gave them permission to do that
beyond just
general obliviousness or arrogance is
they look and they like especially if
they're brand new they're still a
student or their brand or they're
or they're just new to the business in
one way or another
they'll look and they'll say okay well i
have a hundred followers
and i'm talking to people that have tens
of thousands or hundreds of thousands of
followers
so they think they're very anonymous and
they think that they're
sort of lost in the crowd and that that
that somehow translates into
it not counting and i think they also
simultaneously the other
part of the double whammy is that they
they overestimate how big the industry
is and they don't realize especially
when you boil it down to
the development community the games
journalists community the games writer
community
all these subsets you know
i rarely meet a composer that i've just
genuinely
never heard of like it's really after a
few years in the business you realize
it's a small community so when you're
one of those people
like there are a couple composers i know
that they they don't realize the damage
they've already done to their career
because
everyone i know has talked about this
person because of
that cavalier tweet or that douchey
facebook post or something
and they think that no one notices and
then meanwhile here's you know
here's 10 composers working on 30
different games that you've all heard of
and they all know who this person is
because
that a screenshot of that got shared
around is like can you believe what this
person said
so they think it's a smaller they think
it's a larger
community than it is and it's a shame
because you know
and and you know i've had a few
instances of
where someone sent me you know a direct
message along
you know that was in that vein you know
of like
here's you know everything that you
don't know or that
you're doing wrong or whatever and i've
written back to them and i've tried to
very kindly say look
i'm a very non-vindictive person i am
not the type of person to screenshot
this [ __ ] and
share it around or whatever and so
please take it as
like a shot across the bow that i'm
explaining to you the massive error
you're making yeah and and and and as a
teachable moment
because i'm not going to hold your feet
to the fire over this but very
few other people will have this attitude
like people will just laugh and
screenshot it and my foot slipped it's
kind of like a drop
of twitter right yeah he can't help but
create music
even in the moment of accident it just
arrives um it was john williams i think
that said no
the um it sounds the way austin's
saying it there's a risk that somewhat
to someone it sounds like
kind of a grand conspiracy that there's
a list somewhere if there is
no no no certainly not about it people
just but it's more just people are
people
like yeah you'll never believe the dumb
[ __ ] someone said to me today like
they'll you know in the same way as
anyone talks with their friends i think
what people sometimes underestimate is
the games industry is like a very small
group of people
um and reputation matters a lot like
that's a good distinction a reputation
it's not a it's not a hyperactively
catty gossipy
mean girlies mean girlsy kind of
environment it is just literally humans
being humans
and it usually starts in an innocuous
way like person
a the young oblivious
doesn't realize they're making a
horrible mistake or doesn't care but
most likely just don't realize they are
doing something very
ill-advised says something to person b
and then person b
turns to person c and says how should i
respond to this and then person c
is the one that's like the little gossip
that says you know
did you see what person a did or
whatever so it's like so it's not
we all have a friend who's person c
right like we might i totally
do my brain went i know who my
personality is no i visualize that
person in my mind immediately and it's a
person who i specifically
won't mention like a funny interaction
like this because i know it will just
spread and like destroy
they will look through someone's twitter
timeline for four days straight
tell me all the [ __ ] that i'm like i
just mentioned one tweet
so the title of today's episode is don't
be the person don't be person c
i can stand by that message yeah i do
think it's a it's a hard thing because
you don't know the lesson until you've
learned it when you become
twitter's antagonist for the day so
that's definitely a big thing i have
seen people routinely
again usually with arrogance uh hurt
their careers in
games journalism however i do think it
is important for that field for you to
be on twitter i do think it is
the best way especially because you know
that the way that that works for most
people the way it worked for me is to go
from freelancing to part-time to
full-time is generally the roadmap and
the best way to get freelance work is to
be actively on twitter where people are
advertising needing freelance writers
making those contacts with editors etc i
think it is very very important um but
yeah you can also do more harm than good
as is social media in a nutshell
really and it's obviously helped my
career tremendously
um in in a lot of different ways while
also you know deteriorating my mental
health in a bunch of ways so there's a
balance across the board for all of it
uh that is is worth looking at and
here's a question doesn't it because i
i've definitely had those days where i'm
like
maybe i'm just going to shut down all of
my accounts and just completely go off
like i've definitely had i think of my
version at least of what you're
describing but here's my question for
the two of you
do you find that it's the drag
force of it is primarily the result of
what people are saying directly to you
in response to your own tweets or is it
just from looking at your timeline of
like doom scrolling and that kind of
thing
yeah i have my notifications off so i
only see things that people
i follow say to me on twitter at this
point i don't see anything anyone else
says to me so
that means absolutely nothing to me um
the things people say to me are fine
it is the the constant needing to know
every negative thing all the time that
just makes me go [ __ ] hell but i also
sometimes struggle with um
feeling like i'm a person who tries to
do a lot of good and anytime that i make
a mistake
people are so obsessed with the mistake
that it feels like people
don't want me to be good it's like i'm
trying so hard to stick to this thing
and you keep trying to make something
bad and i'm just trying to do the right
thing all the time and i really am
and i feel like i struggle with that a
lot on social media as well as like the
good's just never good enough and the
bad is the worst and sometimes it's like
this pressure it just gets
very frustrating like trying to do
something good
in a world that wants you to fail like
uh any time that i
announce a new charity campaign
basically there will be someone being
like oh how much money does she make
from this it's zero but there's
conspiracy theories i can't even accept
the money legally
um or like is it something that you're
signaling just like all this [ __ ] that
comes up but i'm just like just trying
to do something good
stop is it one of those because i'm i'm
curious if you
if if those voices are the unignorable
vanishingly small minority or if it
actually because for me that's always
the case
one person will write something shitty
and it immediately i can't i can't see
the 99 positives anymore because it's
just
i think it's just human nature um is
that
you're not designed to you're
biologically not designed to be able to
process
people's opinions like we are all i'm
yeah we're all like meant to live in
little villages like we're
not supposed to have thousands of people
talk to us every day
i'm not meant to know that 70 000 people
will hear something i say on the
internet that is
terrible that is an awful awful that
message it's a
it's an empathy well in fairness you've
had that you're an authentic person it's
a nightmare
your audio has been terrible people
listening to this you've saved yourself
um no i don't think anyone i've been
supposed
[Laughter]
i don't think any one comment ever
bothers me or spirals me mine is it's a
pressure thing of like an amount of them
i don't think i ever read one comment
and go
today's burn to the ground it's only
ever a volume
rather than an individual comment that
gets to me sometimes and it
the only time that it does put pressure
on me is when i'm like i'm trying to do
the right thing and i feel like the
world doesn't want me to do the right
thing
that is could consider not doing the
right thing
i'm driven to you know i very
compulsively want to and
my idea of the right thing might not be
the objectively right thing i could be
wrong all the time but i try very hard
to do the right
thing um yeah but i'm saying just throw
throw the super villain thing on
for i don't know austin and i feel like
the world wants me to and i don't i
don't want to do it give the people
what they want elana i think the
heartbreaking is
a horrible moment he's just trying to be
nice i think the the horrible thing here
is in that
in that scenario where alan's trying to
do a nice thing and someone's kind of
laying into her for
a conspiracy theory or a detail or
whatever it's always awesome
both yeah it's always honest i'm still
not convinced of the game's writer thing
both those people are being manipulated
by software
to bash into each other and that's
that's the aspect i find heartbreaking
that your day is worse because of like
you said a compound element of those
interactions
their days were sorry your day's worse
because about their days worse because
of it
because they've been shown the the you
know they
the your tweet has been shown to that
person because the
uncertainty not intelligently it yeah it
doesn't know
they're like yeah it's not intelligent
it's really stupid but it's just
stupid enough that it can achieve an
outcome that's negatively
damaging both of you and that's the
that's the bit i find heartbreaking
that's something i try and remind myself
in those moments is
this person probably would like open a
door for me
um in real life like this we have not
meant to be against each other there are
truly awful people and there's no common
ground with them
but most of those interactions that are
like awkward or like
oh that's i think probably you weren't
trying to be a jerk but you were and
those kind of compounding
that's just that's just a machine making
our days worse
to make us keep coming back and trying
to hunt that endorphin rush it's a
horrible it's a real thing on youtube
like
i feel like i've really cut my my social
media usage back i do not spend very
much time on twitter anymore and most of
the bad news that i hear about is
through other people telling me about
what they read on twitter other than
seeing it myself and sometimes i'm
conflicted like i don't know where i
uh land on the idea that i am ignorant
about things um
like i didn't know about major news that
happened yesterday until someone told me
and i was like well [ __ ] i probably
should have known about this um but i
won't know
if i'm not looking at twitter because i
don't you know watch any tv or anything
i'm still not sure how i feel about that
morally
it begs the question of are you in a
position to do something about it
where you knowing a day later
made a an impact that you have a hard
time stomaching because i do think that
that
you know used to be the next morning's
paper
uh or maybe the evening news was how
like the whole world found out about
things
and generally the world functioned
well you know like yeah ever improving
there were some criticisms i think i
think there were some problems
i think i think in the past i'm not
saying the world was perfect and we've
backslid but i do think that
because i've i've gone through exactly
what you're talking about alana where
i'll
all like i have a i have a friend where
we'll
work you know we'll share like if you
see a headline or something that's
particularly
nauseating or something like we we got
into this pattern of
sharing those back and forth be like can
you believe this [ __ ] and then at some
point i think he
matured faster than me because i would
share like some
horrible hot take from someone on
twitter or something and he would he'd
go
why are you still following that person
and he was like i felt judged that i
thought oh you're right i could have
opted out of this [ __ ] why am i
why am i subjecting myself i have a
thing with a couple of friends where at
this point i have to be like why are you
telling me this i wouldn't have known
about this trash if you didn't
i didn't need to know this this i would
my day would have been great without
this i didn't need to know
but then some of it i don't know i just
feel like it's a privilege i feel like
it's a
a thing that i should be aware of is
that there are a lot of people
especially in like the content creation
space who do need to
constantly be on twitter to uh to
network to grow the people they're
streaming with to
you know have access to all these things
that i can just conveniently like peace
out of
and uh but i don't see a problem even if
that is explicitly
privileged as you are labeling it i
you've earned that haven't you i mean
like to me that that isn't
you've not it's not like you have a
moral obligation it's it from my
perspective i don't see the argument for
that
i don't there could be one but i i don't
see it i don't necessarily
uh in some cases yeah i'm not going to
say explicitly yes i earned it when you
know most of the people that i'm
referring to are people of color so it's
not like i earned
it but you know i have been working in
the field for 10 years and and it spent
a very long time working for major
outlets to build an audience so it
didn't happen overnight it took her
first that's all i'm referring to
yeah i would agree with that but again
like it's i just i just feel like i
don't know the answer to it yet i don't
know
how i feel about what i'm currently
doing which is i tweet something and
then i just
leave um and the only time where i will
really look at my feed is
bathroom so i'm frequently uh tweeting
while peeing just so you're aware
or in a lunch break or if i don't have
anything else to do that makes it worse
you tweet us now please stop dming us
then that's not good
yes i've exposed myself it's very true
you've ruined the whole sometimes if i
can't fall asleep but like
yeah i i i i'm very much doing what i
would consider like
uh a swoop and poop i just like sort of
post the tweet and then peace out like a
bird
just [ __ ] it out and then i leave and i
forget that i even said it flight
pretty much we've really hit all of the
bodily functions on this episode yeah
yeah
i think yeah it's good truly logical
play watch listen
uh i will say just like across the board
i you know i've watched a lot of people
get very addicted to social media and
you gotta recognize how much of it is
negative
i'm not gonna rule out the importance of
it i'm not gonna say it didn't help my
career because it absolutely did
especially again journalism very
important but
man we be using it too much and i think
sometimes forgetting that twitter is not
real life
not everyone in the real world is going
to yell it to you for everything
they are different things even if i
think they have more of an influence
than
probably the laws are willing to admit
at this point it's we probably don't
have enough accountability for what they
can impact but
i do i will just add one little a
you know final comment onto that which
is i do think that the one
sort of consistent saving grace it has
is that if you resist your own primal
instincts towards that negativity
you'll tend to get a lot less of it back
and i use my friends brian and emilia
uh as a good example that you know the
the actors from
detroit become human who started uh
streaming on twitch a lot they're
they're like the most ultra positive
upbeat let's all be nice to each other
and they're very single-minded like
they're not
they don't scrub out the human aspect of
like some days are good and bad and that
kind of thing
but they're very conscientious about
putting positive vibes out there and the
result is that when you scrub through
their replies on twitter or their
comment thread on twitch and whatnot
it's they've attracted an audience that
is exactly the same way
and it's and it's like and i remember i
asked him once you know you've got such
a wonderful community
and he said it's just cause that's what
we put out there it's there's no secret
to it you know so if you
if you resist your own desire to be like
what the [ __ ] is this about something
you'll tend to get less it's not a
one-to-one this isn't a secret bullet
i'm not trying to over
over smooth like i'm not trying to cast
an overly simplistic
view of it but i just think you know
they're a good testament to
kind of garbage in garbage out as as
a as a way to look at these things it
also helps
you reframe oh sorry no go ahead
i was going to say i found um kind of
funny stuff
second mentioned kind of funny in this
episode kind of interesting on this
because kind of funny had that
that approach and that attitude for
quite some time like and
they they were very much like we're a
positive place on the internet like we
want good vibes only
and it was it was interesting last year
i think like a lot of people they were
reappraising that
you know with the black lives matter
movement and and
the moment that we were in where we're
all looking all of these things
and i um i actually kind of liked where
they kind of i think greg kind of
publicly said like
look that's not good enough anymore
ultimately and we
they had allowed some elements of neg of
this
horrible stuff to exist in their
community because it's
ignore the comments you know that kind
of attitude of like yeah we don't need
to worry about this
and they had fostered some some
negativity so i think there's
that to me is like the the the god's
tier next level of what you're
describing is kind of
positivity but with rules with with kind
of
not not necessarily rules but with
boundaries where you can kind of you
build a positive community
but you also when you have to step in
you step in i think that's something
i've seen the switch in the way kind of
funny handles their community
um i think it's generally a positive
thing like i think that it seems to have
made their content better they're um
you know there's a lot more diverse
voices on their on their network there's
a lot more people in their community
than there were like it feels like
there's a
uh some lessons learned there which i
thought was interesting and it's it's
basically just
building on what you were saying austin
that that's like i feel like that's the
next level that you get to
after positivity positivity positivity
establishing those rules and those
boundaries i think that's true of life
as well right we all do that we all
we all go through the stage where we
want everyone to like us and then we
start to get picky about our friends
later in life and we go okay we're gonna
let's put some boundaries up you know
i think kind of funny are also in a
position that a lot of people aren't
though where they make most of their
money from ads and patreon
not from like a youtube view or a twitch
subscription which means that they are
allowed to do those things
um it is a little bit different for them
like i don't think i could make a
patreon ever again because some of the
most serious stalker issues i had came
from patreon where i was still just
posting gaming content
uh but i would not feel comfortable
doing what kind of funny does where they
get to have video calls or send
postcards ever again in my life there's
no way
because it creates that artificial
intimacy with the audience
two of them that like had to end up
being police reports one currently
ongoing came from patreon just because
it was people feeling like they had a
little bit more access to me i will
never comfortably be
able to do that again they can do that
um and that's that's great for them
um and means that they can you know be a
little stricter about what they they
take and what they don't take in terms
of audience and also even the time that
they put into moderating
their stuff so yeah i agree with that
and i definitely appreciated their
approach to being like hey
we don't want some of you here but i
don't think everyone can do that either
i will say to the positivity comment
every stream i do
uh is for charity and i think having
that um
is like to just completely own the
selfish nature of it
such a positive feeling for me too so
making that choice
to use the internet um to try to share
something positive
you have to how much of a cut am i
taking not
damn it but if you're not taking a cut
you better at least be miserable
otherwise it's not truly selfless i'm
sorry
yeah that's a good point uh but uh
that's the thing where like i'm doing
this thing
that then i see people raise a bunch of
money and then i get to have the
experience of holy [ __ ] like what you
people did
uh that's just this constant loop of of
actively having this positive feedback
and of being amazed every single time
that a charity goal is hit
and that's something that i'm making the
choice to positively participate in that
it'd be very easy to just not
do so there are definitely choices you
can make on social media to make things
more positive and including how you
engage with people like
uh since changing my tweet notifications
to just followers sometimes i do miss
when i'd have someone who was following
me like a really good joke like is one
of my favorites if there's a tweet chain
of people i don't know like four in a
row making really good jokes and i'm
like this is very good content
and i don't know them like i love that
stuff and i'm kind of missing that but
for the most part i just there's just so
much on that app that i don't [ __ ]
want to see it
but i do yeah i do want to acknowledge a
lot of people probably should be
um you do need to use it for your
careers but but there's there are
limits to that and you've got to be
careful with it etc but i i feel like we
didn't really have a hard answer like
mine for journalism is a hard yes
you guys were like kind of maybe in some
cases yes but not entirely necessary i
feel like was where we landed on that i
think it's one tool in the toolbox
i've definitely hired people from
twitter but i've also hired people
from art station or people from
a lot of recommendations and you know
that kind of thing i would i would i
think a big part of
a big side effect of the way everyone is
connected is i think people
think the way into the games industry is
to like become
friends with a famous game developer and
actually
i think often it's about community
forming more locally like basically like
you don't need to you don't need to
become a star
on social media you can just be someone
who knows people
in their you know in their local scene
good reputation
very true yeah you don't need to like
like the
there's you know someone someone i was
in the process of trying to hire didn't
work out in the end unfortunately
um recently was someone who has
not got massive social media presence
but was just someone who i
kept hearing their name from everyone
who'd worked with them like this is just
a really cool person to work with
um and and that's you know that's how it
got to me
um that's the that that reputation this
it's the it's the positive side of
whilst it was talking about earlier that
kind of
people are still people and and working
with people getting a sense of community
in that way
does work and does find a way i think
it's one tool i think
if you're someone who is drawn to it and
it works for you great
um don't post stupid stuff on an account
that you're trying to use
to get a job but other than that sure
yeah
but there goes i i've had portfolio sent
to me where like it's not just a twitter
thing
i've had show reels i literally have
showreel sent to me once
which featured um like a pornographic
scene
i'm like what job do you think this will
this is going to get you
like where i mean i guess we gave you an
instant job
it ended up landing uh this actor the
role of hex uh
[Laughter]
that was the name of the movie i think
that he was
[Laughter]
oh
my answer is basically the same you know
all i was
sort of getting at before is if i look
at somebody's
um twitter feed and i feel like it's a
marketing stream
i'm very uninterested but if i feel like
it's a way to genuinely get to know them
because they find
their voice in tweet form um
then then then it's you know then it's
enjoyable like the two of you that's
something that both of you have common
in common is like you i don't feel like
i'm having a wildly
different interaction with you now than
if we were tweeting back and forth about
something
because you you have found a translation
to your honest
self in that medium and that's so when i
say
to folks if you think that this needs to
be important just ask yourself if you
can be honestly yourself
not misrepresent yourself and how you
would treat other people and how you
would represent your ideas and your
enthusiasms about this
and that and the rest and your
tactfulness about this or that
and and if and if it just feels like
it's just
here's i'm i'm hawking my wares um
you know then it's probably going to be
a lot less interesting yeah
it's the the hawking the wares has
become ridiculous with artists with this
nft nonsense like the number of concepts
i follow who now have just turned their
entire twitter into
nft really yeah me too yeah it's a lot
some of it's very cool the art's great
the tech bros using the art community to
shepherd their
nonsense currency into mainstream
articles not so much
i've seen zero uh i i saw a few articles
when the first kind of initial wave of
excitement happened about
maybe this would be a gateway for
musicians to finally have a
really profitable like like because i
saw there was a baby musicians done
stuff with it
they've been i don't know of any i i saw
there was one band
that i it was a pretty big band i'm
blanking on who it was
but it's a relatively big group that
decided they were going to use nfts as
the exclusive
uh way of releasing their next album as
an experiment and there was
there was a write-up about it saying you
know in the post-streaming world
the music industry has been looking
around for what is going to be our
solution to figuring out a way to
try to reclaim some of our prior numbers
and they said maybe
maybe this is it and i thought
interesting maybe it is that was about
as far as like the heartbreaking aspect
is i don't begrudge any artist for
getting paid like that's a good thing
i'm pro artist getting paid i just wish
it wasn't
such a horrible kind of industry that's
you think it's going to be exploited i
don't i do not know enough about it um
i'd be down to have an episode where we
talk about it but i feel like i would
need to go and research because i've
really not looked into nfc i've had a
tab open on my screen for about a month
called nft is explained from like an
npr let's try and do it let's try and
make that happen
which means it's literally never going
to happen if you ever say
let's do this yeah and uh this podcast
will not ever
the heisenberg uncertainty principle of
play watch listen means that
all it's going to happen is at a topic
non-fungible token for this episode that
we're going to do
because we've done that you know i don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
because i you've lost this no it's
overhead's just a report
um anyway we really appreciate everyone
who works in qa you're all underrated
thank you for your work bye